some of you might remember about a month
ago where we recorded a video with this
one it's cesium it's the Emperor of
alkali metals but you know we've been
looking at the YouTube feedback and
we've been really astonished with the
number of people that have one
interested in the science and and to
really want to egg us on to do something
a little bit mad
so I'm unfortunately I'm not going to
put this into water today because it's
far too expensive but what I did do was
that me and Neil had a look at the
chemicals purchasing database at the
University and we spent about 60 pounds
of our own hard-earned money to buy a
small sample of cesium which yes you
guessed it we're going to throw into
water today many people get quite
excited about cesium because they've
seen a very famous video which predates
YouTube but I think now has seen many
places in which somebody drops a tiny
piece of cesium into water and it
explodes enough to break the vessel that
the cesium is in so some of you have
noticed the stoic Neil Barnes at senior
technician in on the project and Neil's
been really really busy last Friday he
designed and built a specific piece of
apparatus to liberate the cesium from
its glass surroundings or its file we
pulled a string
some of you might have heard of this
like Large Hadron Collider that they've
got in Switzerland in CERN this is
actually a small metallic Collider that
we're going to use to liberate our
cesium and study some of its chemistry
and the reason that cesium is so
reactive is that the atoms of cesium are
very large much larger than rubidium
sodium and potassium and so the reaction
with water which removes an electron
from the cesium atom is much easier
because it needs less energy so if
there's less energy needed to remove the
electron from the cesium then there's
more energy left to release as heat so
we're behind the boiler shed which is at
the back of the department simply
because it allows us to control the
environment a little bit more so back by
popular demand cesium mark - we have a
gram of cesium in a glass vial we have
our remote control device let's see what
happens when we put it into water we've
actually got some students watching I
don't know perhaps they rigged their
original experiment to explode the thing
but this has become a classic and I
think many of our viewers expect us to
have a bigger and better explosion than
they did so here's our cesium sitting in
the bottom of the little tube and now
we're going to actuate the small
metallic Collider to initiate the
reaction so time for the safety and
let's see what happens
ready guys
I've never seen caesium react with water
and it might be quite exciting
while you can see it was a very vigorous
reaction and the whole of that gram of
caesium reacted instantaneously the
moment it hit the water nice purple
flare really quite nice chemistry